we are back and it's our Gusty hour
everybody and our next guest is a very
talented actor and an amazing musician
he does it all he's one of the
bestselling Latin artist out there right
now he is nominated this year for best
Latin album at the Grammys which is
incredible his latest album is called
Don Juan you can check it out wherever
you get your music say hello to
maluma
[Applause]
I know I was kidding I know it's I know
I was like it gets a little in case you
guys forget a uh Christmas tree yes I
love it green is my favorite color oh
really mine is well mine is purple but
for today's yeah so um anyway I have to
say what's your gutsiest moment you feel
like in life well actually I brought a
picture okay yeah I need show you guys
yeah okay now in this picture is totally
like like pink you see mhm it's not the
gsy moment though it's not no no no no
this was the the first time that I went
on tour after Co and I was the first
Latino artist like actually to say that
I want to tour again after covid it was
pretty dangerous but it was like the the
Pioneer after covid hit so bad so I felt
like okay I need to no that is a guty
moment yeah I need to yeah I need to do
and after that I saw all my colleagues
doing it at the same time so that was
like pretty nice to be the first first
artist that's really Brave cuz people
were getting a lot of like uh should we
do it should we not do it it was very
yeah yeah of course we we we did it in a
pretty responsible way of course because
it was kind of tough it was 2019 you
know so but it was a great a great Tour
all the Arenas were sold out thank God
so it was beautiful yeah um well
congratulations you're nominated for
another Grammy thank you
yeah so exciting thank you I I'm going
to tell you my first Grammys I ever went
to was actually the Latin gramys it was
my first one I did a duet and I and they
asked me to sing and I was like sure way
but I love the American gr I love the
English gramys but the Latin gramys were
so great they were so passionate and so
I love the performances it was a really
wonderful experience thank you you know
that I've never been like performing at
the Grammys like the American Grammys
all been performing in Lon Grammys but
we're waiting for this opportunity
because there is a big thing for me you
know like being nominated to the
American gramms with an album that is
full in Spanish yeah the whole album
that's a big deal yeah it's great that's
beautiful I feel happy I want to perform
yeah that's like my dream to go there
perform and and taking the Grammy with
me and taking to Colombia you know for
my Latino community that would be that
would be you know what's funny is you
just remind me of something that's
that's always my goal I always tell God
I'm like I don't care if I win but I
really want to perform I love performing
cuz I feel like that's the best way to
sell yourself to an audience that might
not know you yet is the performance part
that's my favorite part that's where I
love the most going perform have fun see
my friends some colleagues you know it's
a it's a great night let's see what
happens in this Awards but if you guys
are watching me right now please vote
for me
yeah absolutely absolutely I will vote
for you I'm a voter okay be sure to
check out maluma's latest album It's
called Don Juan it's out now
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home